ou de manger
stéphanie doit se nourrir à l'aide d'une
seringue depuis quelques jours elle ne
peut plus sortir du lit tellement elle a
été rouée de coups par son ex conjoint
ce soir elle voulait que chaque mois
j'ai dit non
en effet à sa tête en corse et en
effaçant il refusait de quitter la
maison alors qu'elle avait mis fin à la
relation au mois de juillet il m'a pris
mais ma vie quand la france va mal on va
les rendre dans l'erreur
c'est l'affiché retard tête première ils
l'ont ensuite frappé puis étranglée
quand elle a repris ses esprits elle
entendu qu'ils montaient à laitages vers
la chambre de leurs deux garçons est
français qu'il n'est absolument pas quoi
faire elle lui a alors fait croire
qu'elle avait tout oublié elle a joué la
comédie si bien que son ex conjointe a
appelé la police pour dire qu'elle
s'était blessée elle-même ce qui s'est
retourné contre lui
la police a appelé à son tour la mère de
stéphanie en pleine nuit pour qu'elles
viennent chercher les enfants elle est
allée voir sa fille à l'hôpital le
lendemain car je n'ai vu belle bronca
lorsqu'il est exposé avec le nez et la
mâchoire fracturée
elle était méconnaissable
son ex conjoint est détenu il fait face
à quatre chefs d'accusation dont
tentative de meurtre
stéphanie se repose maintenant chez sa
mère et des amis ont lancé une campagne
de sociaux financement pour l'aider à
payer les factures pendant ce temps près
vous avez accepté avec stéphanie 2 de
témoigner aujourd'hui pour est important
pour nous parce que sarah wright sa
réponse d'ici là bien pu me hisser en
fait rendu à 18 heures j'en étais vieira
à s'arrêter bien que si je réponds en
contrat car un risque que ce soit juste
des paroles telles que ça serait pas
arrivé
elle invite les autres à ne pas fermer
les yeux ici sébastien desrosiers radio
canada morin